what fresh hell is this after a 10-year
absence from the silver screen
hellboy made his return in a gory
two-hour reboot to the franchise
amid all the crushed skulls the film
leaves several loose ends in its wake
so let's try making some sense of that
unruly ending spoilers ahead
hellboy's titular half-man
half-hellbeast is portrayed by stranger
things david harbour
who fills the formidable shoes of ron
perlman the actor who starred in
guillermo del toro's hellboy films
the film grabs imagery from the original
comic book series by mike mignola
craving plot points and characters from
the wild hunt among several others
hellboy works for the bureau of
paranormal research and defense
battling supernatural creepos alongside
his adoptive father professor trevor
broome played by deadwood's ian mcshane
throughout the film hellboy is hot on
the trail of a spiteful witch named
nimoy the blood queen
portrayed by mila yovovich in the
flashback sequence that opens the film
nimoy is chopped a bit by none other
than king arthur
who rips her apart with his mighty sword
excalibur nimoy's body parts are
scattered throughout the land and remain
buried for 1500 years
alas she's eventually pieced back
together by her willing supplicant
the humanoid warthog grew a catch now
hellboy must stop nimoy before she
destroys humanity
beneath all the rotting flesh and gouged
eyeballs this is the story of a creature
searching for his place in the world
if we were to boil down the character's
central dilemma we'd say he vacillates
between sympathizing with the
supernatural world and siding with
humans
as the film lunges toward its conclusion
we learn that hellboy is the spawn of a
demon and a witch of arthurian descent
in the final confrontation nimoy the
blood queen temporarily
seduces hellboy to the dark side after
killing professor broome before his eyes
hellboy is garland in a kicky crown of
hellflame and immediately grows his
horns out because he's evil now
as nimoy's squadron of unearthly
creatures ripped through the terrified
london streets
hellboy ultimately comes to his senses
and overpowers them away he decapitates
her with excalibur sending her still
screaming head back into the fiery
fathoms of hell
in the film's final set piece hellboy
finds himself on a dangerous mission in
siberia with two trusty cohorts from the
bprd
scrappy spirit medium alice monahan
played by sasha lane
and moody ben daimio played by daniel
day kim
ben is a down low wear jaguar whose
theoretically british accent also has a
penchant for shape-shifting
after dispatching the members of a
secret cabal called the atlantis society
the trio notice a large fish tank
suddenly webbed fingers poke out from
the murky water and touch the glass
surface
if you've ever read the comics or seen
the guillermo del toro films the name
abe sapien will surely mean something to
you although he may be half man and half
amphibian
the character is entirely badass
portrayed by doug jones in the del toro
films abe sapien was once a man named
langdon everett who dabbled in the
occult and paid the ultimate price
he became a half man and half amphibian
monstrosity
those are abe's webbed fingers clearly
clamoring for a sequel
remind me why i keep doing this hellboy
throws not one
but two scenes in the end credits in the
mid-credits scene we find hellboy
mourning the recent death of professor
trevor broome
suddenly the specter of a certain
lobster johnson appears portrayed by
actor thomas hayden church
the ghostly figure wastes no time
telling hellboy evil
is coming johnson also appears in an
earlier flashback making mincemeat out
of a slew of nazi occultists
so who is this guy long story short he's
a beloved character in the hellboy
universe a vigilante who plays by his
own rules
as you just saw johnson is fond of
searing his signature lobster claw
symbol into the foreheads of his enemies
what's not to like about that during his
quest to find nimoue the blood queen
hellboy pays a visit to baba yaga
haggard witch who exists in some far-off
dimension
baba yaga offers hellboy some clues
regarding nimawe's whereabouts
but this intel comes at a price he must
give her one of his eyeballs
he agrees but manages to escape baba
yaga with both eyeballs intact but in a
post-credits scene baba yaga convinces
an unseen accomplice to murder hellboy
at his earliest convenience
and hand over the hellish eyes she was
promised the los
angeles times seems to think she's
talking to kosha the deathless
a seemingly immortal assassin who
appears in the darkness falls graphic
novel
this theory gels with the fact that baba
yaga assures her henchman she'll
mercifully end his life if he brings her
hellboy's eye
after surviving a movie full of so much
sensory overload
you may be willing to volunteer both of
your own
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one